what's the animal that scares you the
most
men no training
[Laughter]
martians
i think
i think uh you know like those tear
lists of like animals that i could take
in a fight yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know why i just think like a a
deer would just [ __ ] me up i mean they
could yeah like more i think i'd have
more chance of like being able to outwit
a bear or something
or like being oh
has taught me anything don't [ __ ] with
bears which are the ones with like the
massive antlers is it dears are they all
dears i mean
i don't know no maybe not moose but like
there's some caribou i've i've seen some
of them that are [ __ ] insane i mean
moose are like [ __ ] like
insane yeah
like people imagine moose and they're
like oh yeah that's like just a big deal
right i'm like no they're [ __ ]
they're like huge
insanely huge it's it's scary even
though i think i there's like a 0.1
percent chance that i could
live it with a bear encounter yeah
i at least think that i like a deer i'd
have like zero if it wanted to kill me i
feel like it would just chase what he
what what logic are you basing this like
what kind of thing
are you like
the way it looks at me i don't know why
you're talking you're talking about like
the deer from princess monarch okay
they've got a look in their eye ideas
right they got a look in their eye that
says i'm up for blood and i'm i'm not
gonna be talking about deer's the cutest
[ __ ] all the time i mean have you
never been an arrow
we can feed the deers they're like no no
there's like wimp tears chad chad diaz
have you seen those deers when they're
wrestling each other for like mating
purposes oh yeah yeah dude
let's just say if one of these deers
thought i was gonna steal its gf i'm
done like it's i'm dead i think you can
say that about most animals though like
if you were like if you tried to steal
like uh yeah
if you want to go to a frat party i'm
sure you feel the same way as well right
oh this guy's gonna [ __ ] me up
i remember this there's like stories
what logic are you playing there's
absolutely zero logic
just the way it looks so are you saying
that like you can't take on a male deer
but you could take on say like a male
elephant
uh or a male giraffe what would we say
take on an elephant are we saying like
beating
yeah okay i think i don't know why i
just feel like a deer could chase me to
the end of the earth
i feel like a bear my gift like most
animals no no no a bear will get bored
after a while you know
they'll get bored i feel like a deer
clearly never encountered a bear in his
life let's say i climb a 20-foot tree i
know bears can climb trees but i reckon
the deer somehow would just [ __ ] jump
up [ __ ] me up naruto style something i
don't know why i'm just scared of these
deers man these big deers that are
tigers lions do you have like girls
i'll take a tiger i'll [ __ ] it did you
have like a childhood trauma around the
deer
is this just the british in you talking
do you even have tears of course we have
deers in england
are you sure about that don't look at me
do we have no like big the big deals
with the antlers like what's the
difference what are the what are the
ones with like the horns that are like
not they're like all kind of spiky are
you talking about caribous i don't know
what they're called
i know those are spiky antlers like the
ones with like weird shapes i'm talking
about like bambi [ __ ] right no no no the
ones are no horns aren't scary why would
they be scary they have no horns gum
ones are scary
but then but they are but they are also
deers no they are also dude
if i get on the back of a rhino right
what's it gonna do fall on the ground
i'll just jump off it
what about like a ram
a ram i've i've i've been with the ram i
befriended the rams we were friends so
so so you you don't find rams scary no
no they're just they're just kind of
like little [ __ ]
they're just kind of like drama queens
you can you can you can you can talk to
them
you can tell you can't you can't really
talk with me yeah the conversation with
the deer
yeah
this isn't what bring them like one
tablespoon it's just a deer right
those would [ __ ] you up this is the mail
yeah silly you're getting impaled bro
you'll be in the tree like
i mean i'm not not going to get off the
tree i'm not not saying they won't [ __ ]
you up but
i'd rather take on that than a [ __ ]
bear yeah as well because when you see
that you think it's cute right you think
oh it's cute and then it [ __ ] stabs
you right a bear you're not getting
anywhere near that you're cautious right
it's about the position no i'm not going
anywhere near a thing that has horns
like that but they taste good though so
i'd understand why you might go now
so if theirs tasted good would you
maybe
this is one of those things where it's
just like it's gonna make me look stupid
this argument but it's just pure like
gut like this is no logic whatsoever
this is just my gut so wait is is deer
like s t for you like s t is scary
i still will [ __ ] you up and you didn't
expect it
bear is 80 because i know it i know it's
gonna [ __ ] me up but also it might not
it might get bored it might just leave
me alone
but what are you getting this idea that
dears are so [ __ ] aggressive yeah
i've i've seen videos man
i've seen videos of bears being
aggressive probably because some dumbass
is provoking a deer right like yeah of
course they're gonna get pissed off i
don't know you know i just think that uh
bears are you know friendly because my
experience with most deers like even
ones like that is that you go like
[ __ ] in a few again in a
meter trying to make any sense this is
i
50
all just guts no you're not you're not
making sense i know i know it doesn't i
know this isn't making it why we're
trying to glean some sense out of it
yeah but
like tigers are scary
but also you know the tiger king seemed
like he had a good hand of it so maybe
i mean it is like it is he slapped them
with his uh his stick and they let go of
him so if i just give him a little get
off
stop that
yeah that was the problem with like all
the prey that you see they weren't like
they weren't like oh i'll use the slap
method because you don't have a big
enough stick you know obviously
everyone's gonna die dangerous bear is
it the red one the red bear
black grizzly bear isn't the black one
okay
i'll pull a bit oh yeah there was like a
story from like um
that i think brian blessed you know
brian blessed he's a very famous british
guy
he he's this really famous british guy
who has like yes the most booming voice
like this right and apparently he was in
the arctic filming something and a polar
bear came up and i think he either
punched the polar bear in the face or he
screamed at the polar bear and it ran
away scared
this story so i'd like to think that i
could if it is true that you could scare
a polar bear from shouting at it i think
i'll be all right well i mean
bucky has told me that like the best way
to beat a bear is to punch into the nose
yeah i heard that you could punch it in
there but probably not the grizzly bear
probably just
yeah well i mean if you're fast enough
right
i mean not fast
i mean at that point you're lucky
at that point you're kind of playing
gacha with your life you know yeah
it's the same thing with sharks right if
you if you punch a shark in the nose
then it'll just be like is that is that
true i don't know
i've tried it i wouldn't try it i mean
i'm not going to try it but you know
like nature's like world's slowest punch
underwater punch nature's literally
giving them a weak point
i punched the shark for massive touches
where you're gonna punch a deer huh you
can't punch it anywhere it's got
big spiky things right i feel like i
feel like you could like you know
dodge at the last moment yeah you can
like devil back yeah
what are you talking about bears are
[ __ ] fast as [ __ ] what have you seen
about huh this is the most dumb
conversation we've ever had
you're so like if you see a bear like
like a grizzly bear you are not running
away from that no you can't now run a
bit yeah no but like the best tactic is
that you can outrun your mates maybe i
can maybe i can shout at it ask it
kindly to stop
you know it's like
okay let's have
why don't we ask survivors of bears
right what they did to survive the bear
uh i like to ask how many bear survivors
do you know there's got to be a few out
there
i'm pretty
there are sure yeah because no one talks
about it because everyone sometimes
deals because they know if they talk
then it's going to come back
is going to come back for something then
comes back with his family like
you maybe you'll be
smitten
it's like how many horror movies are
there with deers as like the main
monster that's because [ __ ] [ __ ]
people are too scared to talk about
dears
like the next like when's the next deer
coming on in the godzilla trilogy or
whatever man
king kong vs king kong and godzilla
versus deer they need to tag team the
ultimate monster do you man it can it
can go run super fast launch itself in
with those hooks you know you're done gg
so would you say the deer is the most
powerful animal
it's the most powerful
spiritually if it was an animal like
battle royale would you pick deer no
no who would you pick for an animal
battle royal animal kingdom battle royal
um
i'm definitely picking polar bear for
sure i feel like you're going for low
hanging fruit i feel like there's
probably something stronger yeah because
i'm trying to win yeah
i feel like there's probably better
animals maybe if you ask tls the tia zoo
guy i'm sure boris
walrus i don't think so okay okay the
only reason i say this is because i i
literally saw a video where like a polar
bear truck was like [ __ ] starving
hadn't eaten for a while uh so he was
trying to hunt and he comes across these
like this group of walruses i don't know
what the proper word is the herd
i don't know and like he literally tried
to like try to take a bite out of any
walrus yeah right and the hides were
like so thick that he that like he
couldn't he couldn't grab on and walls
just like shook him off and he tried
with like several walruses and like he
just failed so maybe maybe it's walruses
that are at the top of the [ __ ] food
chain and we just never thought about it
the honey badger that one's like a scary
one right
i would like a [ __ ] i think the polar
bear would destroy the honey badger i
don't know man
i mean human versus honey badger yeah
the honey badger is probably gonna win
yeah but like you know because i don't
want to [ __ ] with a honey badger
what is a honey badger it's a badger
that eats honey no it's not no it's not
no yes it is is it primarily honey i
thought it was like this yeah because
it's not [ __ ] crazy isn't the whole
thing but with a honey badger is that
like its height is so thick that like a
bee sting literally can't penetrate it i
don't know that's why they're like that
shit's crazy i i remember i read
something about it shrimp you know
mentorship i know [ __ ] manchester
united
yeah my god like that okay that that's
when nature is [ __ ] cool yeah i just
see fish it's always fish like what's
going on like manchester shrimp is like
the bucky of the scene why does this
fish have like a cannon for an arm like
what's going on with that
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna throw a
fist and create a sonic boom yeah what
happened with evolution what's go like
i'm telling you man evolution in the sea
is [ __ ] like i don't know what's going
on when is the next
like stage above that it's like oh i
throw a punch and a nuclear fusion
happens
black hole with my fist yeah i mean if
you just like sliced up a manta strip
but i think it could possibly like
create a [ __ ] vacuum that sucks sucks
the area and sucks his opponents in so
that's what bucky should have done
instead of imagining a human-sized uh
praying mantis he should have imagined a
human-sized manta shrimp
it's gonna be the one punch man yeah of
course why are we talking about this
again
the one punch man of the sea you know
you know what one uh thing that um i
always
there's like i think this is youtube
videos where like people like kind of uh
go to like nature and they like save the
animals that are like being hunted or
something yeah yeah by other animals
yeah okay right and then they ask like
david attenborough questions like do you
ever feel like you should uh help the
animal that's being hunted and stuff and
he's like no
it's literally nature why would i
[ __ ] interfere yeah like i i don't
understand why people will always make
these videos being like today we're
going to save the fish from being eaten
it's like that's literally the point of
the fish that gets it
it's literally called a food chain yeah
yeah
yeah we just we're just sympathetic
because we're at the top
exactly if we're if we're in the middle
of that if you're like
i'm trying to save my own life
yeah i don't think cavemen uh really
worried about uh what nature was doing
because we were trying our best to
survive as well that's like a seagull
being like i'm gonna save these fish
today
because i feel bad
like no they don't give a [ __ ] they're
gonna eat